all right Kurt
Kurt oh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up born in Hollywood
California you're L.A boy L.A boy
you uh you had Mom and Dad grown up
I did for the first few years of my life
they divorced when I was probably around
five years old and that
kind of kicked off my ultimate awareness
to what we're here to talk about today
you uh
how would you describe what what your
family Dynamic was
um
it was pretty bad it was it was you know
it was um
pretty violent my dad was a big guy and
and was pretty violent towards my mother
um
loud and you know so I kind of grew up
in a pretty tense environment
um you know we were
middle class people my dad was an
executive with with bullocks
clothing line and store chain and
my mother was a nurse and um so it was
it was you know I I don't have a lot of
memory of my my parents together
um actually my one of my first memories
was was finding my mother
trying to commit suicide hanging herself
in the garage
and I was four or five years old and I
am
put the chair back under her feet and
so you think your mom knew what what was
going on oh yeah she knew what was going
on and and she and the way that I became
aware of it after she they separated was
she was always talking a lot about it
you know she she was so tell us what uh
what was what your dad was into my dad
was considered you know one of
California's most prolific and dangerous
um
sexually violent Predators was his
classification
um when he if he looked at his
profile in a sex registry he was he had
that he had that affixed to his
his um
his profile so he was he was um had been
in to prison a number of times and of of
the I believe five times he went to
prison three of those times where as a
result of my going to law enforcement
about information then I had things that
he was you were turning him in involved
in yeah ultimately I did turn him in
which what age did that start
um that that didn't start until I was in
my early 20s um the first time I was in
my early 20s
prior to that one prior to the prayer I
left home at 16 and and prior to that
you know I started to have some
clashes with my father on a physical
level and you know he was a big guy so I
got the short end of it pretty much
because I was still a kid and so I moved
out at 16 and then you're you're a big
guy I'm a big guy he was a big guy he
was even bigger than me he was um
he had played football for the Navy and
he had he was a big guy so he was and
his his victims were
young young females
um not in the family
I have a sister I actually have three
sisters all of them are half-sisters
um to my knowledge to my knowledge he he
did not actually molest any of my
sisters he seemed to have his attraction
out outside the family I think other
kids in the neighborhood kids in the
neighborhood friend children of friends
things like that
so um
it it you know what I what I recall is
that there was always you know this this
upheaval of movement like we needed to
move suddenly from somewhere and it was
and that's when I was small I didn't
really understand
um and you know as it turned out those
were always at a point where something
had happened he had victimized somebody
in the area
either law enforcement or family of that
person was on to it and he was concerned
so we would
we would leave but there was yeah you
know the dynamic of family was pretty
bad
um
you know my mother once they separated
became quite revengeful towards my
father so really never had anything
anything good to say about him and was
very forthcoming about his his activity
as a as a pedophile which I didn't
really at that point didn't really
understand
completely what it meant I mean I heard
the stories but I didn't didn't really
understand it
and then my my mother started doing
things like she had us placed in
juvenile hall when I was just seven
years old
um
so
even with my mother I I didn't have a
very stable communicative type
relationship it was just kind of always
a
drama based situation and she would
you know again it was
whenever whenever the issue of my father
came up it was you know describing these
monstrous type of activities that he was
into and
again at that point it didn't really
totally she knew about it oh she knew
about it you know that she never took
any action against it
um I guess he was you know also like
on the kinky side with her was having
her go out and sleep with other men and
come tell him about it and this kind of
stuff like that so he was
I guess he was you know he had a lot of
sexual drives in different directions
but you know it was those those issues
between adults were never something that
I worried about it was when I finally
you know became to understand really
what he was about I was probably 13
years old
um and there was a local girl in the
neighborhood her brother was a friend of
mine and um one day she brought me this
really really graphic porno magazine and
that was before the internet when we had
magazines
so she brings me this really you know
XXX porn magazine and on the magazine
there was all of this handwriting and my
father was left-handed and I just had
this dramatic Slant with his his
handwriting so I took one look at the
handwriting and I knew
that it was my father had written and it
was directed to her the words were Joy
I'm going to do this to you and this to
you and
so it was at at that moment I have a
very Vivid recollection of at that
moment I I decided that
there just wouldn't be
um there wouldn't be a way for my father
to
be able to any longer like influence me
on a
morality or Integrity kind of level I
just knew that that was over
um so I kind of started
come into those types of conclusions at
a pretty early age
um and and then left home at 16 because
the violent clashes between my dad and I
were getting out of hand somebody was
gonna
and it would have been me probably
excuse me um
somebody would have gotten hurt so um
yeah left home we were living in Palm
Springs at the time in California I
moved down to Huntington Beach my older
brother was living down there and
you know engage in my early adult years
but you know obviously I never forgot
about these issues with my father it was
at that time something that I I wasn't
dwelling on but later on as I
my my I have a half brother and sister
that are younger than me and they both
started telling me of things that were
going on around the house things that he
was doing he had I guess Melissa had a
couple of my sister's friends do you
have any idea of how many victims your
dad had
not an accurate number but just knowing
how prolific he was and how many
instances that did come to my attention
I have little doubt that there were
hundreds of victims that he ultimately
came in contact with in his lifetime
um
there was one instance in when I was
about
eight nine years old we were living in
Oceanside California and um
we were sitting on on the balcony
outside of our apartment and there was
this young girl who was probably maybe a
year and a half old she was just still a
toddler
and
he was she was standing there next to
him and he was just I just remember that
he had his hand up her little dress and
I I remember seeing it and connecting
with it and registering it not really
fully understanding what it meant at
that point but
yeah I guess I knew something was
happening there at that moment that
wasn't right wasn't right and that
needed to be addressed yeah I could see
it yeah wow so that's that's
um yeah I I'm not sure if that's the the
first time I think it probably is maybe
the first time that I actually
physically saw this this going on
um but it could have happened but that
that's just probably the most Vivid
recollection of that that I have so it
was common knowledge in the family it
was common knowledge every and so
my uncle who
he wasn't an a-lister but he was a you
know he was a he was a pretty fairly
prominent actor in Hollywood he he
wasn't a lot of well-known movies and TV
shows and things like that and he didn't
use that
very recognizable Dutch last name he
used an abbreviation of it
and um my uncle told me
um I was probably in my 40s when he he
told me this but my uncle told me that
in fact my grandmother
had molested my father when he was a
baby and that's how he became introduced
to it that this is in fact had been some
sort of
generational thing that had gone on in
the family for many years uncles
yeah
so um
that was
you know my grandmother was a was a very
difficult person and she she was you
know she and I had a lot of clashes
um but it was difficult for me to hear
because when he told me that she had
already passed away and I was like well
you know
why now why are you telling me this now
I mean if this is something that you
know why isn't just a family issue
that's being dealt with and
you know as we talked about uh back in
the back in in the past it seemed to be
an issue that people tended to
sweep under the rug as a way of dealing
with it to protect the the good name of
the family
um embarrassment
um just just shame whatever
for me you know I I I I was never
a victim of sexual abuse as a child but
I was a victim of other types of abuses
as a child and just you know being
manipulated and
Twisted between my two parents and their
vengefulness towards each other I I
the good name and and that never meant
anything to me I just felt that
I needed to step up and and bring this
out in the open
for one reason and one reason only and
that was to potentially protect even one
child if it was just one then great
um
and so
um yeah I I ultimately made that
decision to go to the authorities and
let them know about what my my younger
brother and sister were telling me
um and that resulted in his
his first conviction at my report am I
turning him in and um
he did I think three years and then and
then came out
um
he did three years he just did three
years yeah he was yeah he's he's my dad
was a really charismatic guy people
really loved my dad yeah he he you know
they called him coach Kim like you know
he was the coach like he he could just
go and hang out with the football
coaches and
yeah he just had that and then he would
you know do the God thing or he'd be a
pastor or whatever he just could kind of
jump from
skin to skin pretty pretty pretty easily
um so
um that that Dynamic I think leads to a
lot of people just kind of refusing to
believe it oh I can't believe that you
know you're just a teenager that doesn't
get along with your your dad you know
that's that's normal right so it there
was a lot of things that I think led to
him being able to keep this under the
radar
the fact that it was a a well-known
family Dynamic but yet not one person in
the family chose to
stand up to it in fact my uncle who you
know was the father of one you know my
cousin Kerry is a very beautiful woman
and she was a really pretty kid and and
I can recall my uncle telling me that
oh you know your father is just uh he's
just a flasher you know he he he doesn't
really do anything to hurt them he just
you know shows himself or whatever and
he said if you if your dad did that to
my daughter Carrie I wouldn't even care
and I can just remember just wanting to
fly across the room and
tear into my uncle pretty badly because
I was just like
so yeah that was that was pretty amazing
so that just kind of tells you where you
know once once people get the
perspective of it's keep it quiet it's
no big deal it's really easy for this
type of
victimization to go on for years and
years and years and years until until
somebody finally stands up to it so on
the last the last instance with my
father he ended up getting a 10-year
sentence of which he did seven in prison
and I was telling you that I had become
acquainted with Maureen kanka who was
the mother of Megan canca which is a
person namesake of Megan's Law
and so because I was a witness with the
District Attorney's Office in Riverside
County where he had where he had been
sentenced the district attorney
contacted me and said hey your dad's
going to be getting out in a few weeks
and I just want to let you know and
and so I was just like oh I was upset
and kind of panicked so I I called
Maureen and I said hey this is my dad's
getting out I don't know if there's
anything we can do about this
and
um she said well I'm personal friends
with Dan Lundgren the Attorney General
in California let me see what I can do
and um
a few days later I get a call from the
district attorney again in Riverside and
they're like change of plans he's now
been remanded to on an indefinite hold
to an Atascadero State Hospital which is
a part of the prison system it's
basically a hospital for the criminally
insane
and so he did he did he finished out his
10-year sentence there that he did
finish the final three years there
and then was
given the option of being released but
only if he paid for his own castration
process now I don't know if this is
a chemical castration if it's a physical
removal of his
his you know his bag I don't I don't
know you know I just know that he that
according to what he had told me that it
was a thirty thousand dollar procedure
that he ended up having to pay for and
that was the only way that he got out
ironically a few years later there was a
radio show and I can't remember which
one which ones but
um they were talking to a guy who
claimed to be the first person ever
castrated by the state of California
and released
and I was like that's really interesting
because this happened to my father at
least three years before this so I
believe that there was probably a
process of this going on more on a
secretive type level the state wasn't
talking about it and that they had
decided that there must be some do you
feel like that
cured him in any way
um no no I didn't I don't believe that
it cured him in any way in fact
the first girl that I turned him in for
when I was in my early 20s was a young
lady named Marissa and she was only 11
years old at the time and her mother was
a methamphetamine addict
and my father had some apartments and
someone was giving her mother free rent
and the mother was giving my father
access to Marissa's at 11 years old and
was taking her camping and
yeah so that's that's
the first time that I turned him in and
so ironically after he got out of prison
I told you that I
of the three times that he went to
prison I I met him at the prison Gates
and um was there to give him a ride back
to Los Angeles
for once from Sam Lewis Obispo and the
other one was
somewhere in the central part of the
state
um
and so um
at one point after he was released for
the last time he must have been 70
74 years old 75 years old something like
that and I was out at his home in Palm
Springs
and the phones rings and he keeps
picking up the phone and then hanging up
he's not answering it he's not answering
after like the 10th time he says to me
do you know who that is who's calling me
and I'm like how would I know who's
calling you he says well it's Marissa
but I'm thinking
I knew who Marissa was on that his
victim but
it's Marissa this girl that you you know
I
you turned me in for a minute 12 years
ago so now Marissa's an adult she's 23
24 years old
she actually has a family she's married
and had a couple two or three kids in in
Tennessee I think
but still believed that she was in love
with my father
yeah he's calling him and saying that he
was he never she never considered
herself a victim
he he called and and I said next time
she calls answer the phone and let me
talk to her
because I never talked to her I just
knew about what was going on and but I
had never met her you know so I said
look I'm I'm current I'm the one that
you know turned my dad in for what was
going on between you guys when you were
a child and um and she just was animate
he never victimized me what he did to me
I was okay with he was the best father
figure I ever had I love your dad
I just said just you know I just
kind of you know
didn't plead with her but I just said
look you know you're you're a mom now
you've got your own babies
just just turn away from walk away from
this experience because there is nothing
good here for you and and or for the
people here
bringing into this world as as a mom how
old was your dad at this point 74 75 and
I can remember him
after I got off the phone and I was I
was in tears I I sometimes when I get
mad I start to get teary-eyed so I was
kind of in tears like steaming not my my
ears probably and
I remember he looked at me and he goes
well I think it's pretty cool that a
24-25 year old girl is in love with 75
year old man and I that was kind of like
my uncle's name what he said about his
daughter you know I just about freaking
lost it so
um
as I told you I'm I I ended up going
camping with my dad after that I took
him camping because I wanted to have a a
one-on-one very solitary opportunity to
to say what I had to say to my dad about
this activity and what I felt about his
impact on so many innocent lives
my own not for I really never you know
my dad was not
the greatest dad to me didn't treat me
but I always don't I don't consider
myself to be my dad's greatest victim by
any stretch of the imagination right you
you weren't a victim of him no I was not
a victim of his pedophilia and I and I
was a victim of his you know physical
abuse as a father for young girls yeah
he was he was into young girls and again
he there was some Consciousness there
about the family Dynamic if it's true
about what my uncle said about my
grandmother
um he didn't seem to want to keep it in
the family however as I told you I did
have a younger half-brother and sister
and as it turned out my younger brother
decided to
follow in My Father's Footsteps and also
became a pedophile
was was
when it went in as a as a medic into the
into the into the Navy and was you know
finished really high it went in as an
officer and was about to have a start a
really nice military career and he
finished his training and everything and
he had like three weeks
break before he had to report to duty
and he um I told him man go to Europe go
go do something fun you know I'll go do
something real
and he ended up going back to the
bowling alley in Palm Springs and
hanging out and hooking up with a 13
year old and
ended up raping her at knife points and
um yeah so he ended up getting arrested
for that removed from the military he
did three years there
um and then he um
he got out and
promised to walk the straight line would
never do that again and but ended up
getting back into it and
he he's actually
um there's a fair his case is fairly
well known on the internet actually
because he tried to he
contacted a prostitute and she came and
then well they were together she told
him that she had a 10 year old daughter
and he tried arranging for this woman to
bring a daughter for a
some kind of disgusting threesome so her
pimp was so put off by that he decided
to go to the police and they set my
brother up and ended up giving him 10
years in prison and they made him do the
full 10 years in in Arizona
[Music]
um
just just for trying to think about
doing it which was fine and he got out a
couple years ago and I tried talking to
him and but but I was at his court
martial
um in in from the military and told the
judge look if he like was my father I I
won't be quiet about this if he gets out
and I get any word of his
involvement in this type of activity I'm
I'm going right straight to the
authorities and he should know that loud
and clear
um so yeah
um
I was never I was never involved in
my brother going to prison he managed to
find his way there on his own but this
is a generational
situation in my family you think it's
something learned or do you think it's a
it's a in the in the DNA
I think it's a learned thing I think I
think so much of this this type of
dysfunction is something that that
doesn't
appear without some sort of influence
some sort of impotence for your uncle
your dad your yeah you know my uncle
said that it was my grandmother was
focused on my father but my uncle was
older
um and and it's difficult for me to
believe if she was doing kind of things
that he said she was doing to my father
that she wasn't doing the same thing to
him but that supposedly she had been
victimized by
an uncle and
and on and on and on and on so I you
know all of those kinds of stories just
made it that much more
um
absolute that I had to
you know take some kind of action that
there had to be one person in this whole
picture that that tried to stop this
because I I have a total of eight
brothers and sisters only two full
Brothers but the other six are half
brothers and sisters and they all know
about the situation
and none of them my older brother they
all know about it they all know about it
yeah my older brother is an attorney and
Carlsbad in California and my younger
brother still lives in the same area in
Palm Springs that we grew up in and
where all of this happened and
he just basically they all just
basically ignored my father they just
disconnected from him they didn't have
anything to do with them but they
certainly didn't
take any kind of action any kind of
preventative measure to did you get it
it's no longer alive he's no longer
alive yeah he passed away in um
in 2017
um the story was is that he had fallen
out of bed and broken a hip and laid
there for a couple of days and then had
suffered so much kind of damage from
laying there
intuitively and and I've often been
correct about these kind of
feelings is that he probably victimized
somebody and and somebody
you know probably give him a beat down
and then he
that was you know falling out of bed was
probably the story I can't say for sure
because I don't have those facts but
um who went to the funeral what's that
who went to the funeral uh nobody nobody
no he was cremated by a friend
um
and and because I wasn't you know I
wasn't trying to like lob darts at my
dad like I wasn't trying to take action
but from the from the from a distance
you know I mean like I said I went to
pick him up at the prison gate when he
got out to tell him that I was
feel good about what I did and I'll do
it again if you go there again and I
want you to know that I want you to know
that I don't hate you as a human being
but I'm not I'm not
I'm not standing just trying to protect
some kids yeah I'm just trying to and so
I know that in the
I guess 13 14 years he did in prison I'm
I'm sure that there was
some number of kids that avoided his
his uh his behavior and his
victimization my my brother who himself
who did 10 years in Arizona
um
he had stayed in contact with my dad
they they had enough Common Ground I
guess that they they stayed in contact
and when so when he when he died and he
was cremated
um my brother got out of prison he then
went
to California up near Mammoth where my
father had died and the friend had his
ashes and so my brother sent me some of
my father's ashes which to me was
powerful it was it was it was a good
thing you know it was it was it was a
full circle kind of feeling
um that you know like I said that I
never was hiding from him as a person I
I you know when was his son and dealt
with him on that level and in truth
because truth is to me something that
just can't be it can't be altered it
can't be manipulated it's just the truth
and you either embrace it or you don't
and so I I know that I
I know that I took the correct action
and
you know the reason why I wanted to talk
to you today Mark is because I I'm
hoping that my story you know will reach
even one person you know that might find
themselves in a similar situation that's
a you know that knows that somebody that
they know is is victimizing other people
and that you know there's a million
reasons that might come to mind about
why you shouldn't
take action but at the end of the day
you know we are all a human family right
and and so little children especially
deserve to be protected and
if you're aware that somebody is
victimizing
in particular children but anybody it's
very commendable that you're you have
the courage to speak up well thank you
thank you it's um you know it it
as I told you I don't I no longer carry
that very distinguishable Dutch last
name with the capital s in the middle of
it I did change my name after seeing um
one day watching the news they were
doing an expose on the top 20 Child
predators in California and good old dad
was number nine and I just said
500 to change my name okay I'm doing
that so I changed my name in 2000
2004 I changed mine about 20 years ago
and what does your life look like now
you you moved to New York I moved to New
York um I you know I've I've lived all
over the world I was I lived in
Argentina for a good period of between
2004 and 2011
um
came back to California
out here in New York taking advantage of
a business opportunity I've always been
kind of
kind of a rolling stone I I think you
know
um my father there were some of the
other influences that my father had on
me was that he was kind of a for a
period of my childhood we lived on the
road
um we lived about four years where I
didn't go to school and we traveled
around the country in a in a Chevy van
which I think was actually a period
where he tried to just keep himself away
from people that he could victimize and
I think that that's kind of what I I
recognize from that from that period of
time and it was an interesting period of
time but it also put in me uh you know a
willingness to
to just go wherever my dreams led me and
my goals led me you know I wasn't about
growing up and
staying in the same town and like I was
telling my younger brother on the other
hand is married to his first girlfriend
they had five kids they still live in
Palm Springs where we went to high
school and
it's just a completely different Dynamic
so yeah yeah my life my life is good you
know I know that
these kinds of these kinds of family
Dynamics they take their toll you know
they definitely do like I had a I had a
quadruple bypass at a pretty early age
ironically it was two days prior to my
dad having one he had one two days later
but I was only 38 years old when that
happened to me
and I think um you know yeah when you
grow up in that kind of a household
where there's a lot of tension and a lot
of fear and a lot of anxiety all the
time it's it's you're it's you can you
can develop some kind of habit patterns
and how you deal with and react to life
that ultimately end up not necessarily
being so good for your health so yeah
I've come a long way man I've I've you
know I
I just yeah I just prefer to try to keep
things real and keep things truthful and
um
I'm glad I would I would again encourage
anybody that might find themselves in
kind of a similar position to really
believe in believe in your in yourself
and if you're being led to do the right
thing please do the right thing help
help another another human being help a
child at the end of the day
um it you'll you'll you'll I'm sure be
like me and know in your heart that it
was the right thing to do and I I would
I would do it again as many times as I
had the opportunity to do so so
yeah that's great thank you so much for
sharing your story sure no problem thank
you for letting the truth prevail
thank you everyone needs about a little
more of that yeah yeah the world does
need a little bit more of that I think
you know right now we're going through a
period of time where
you know where the world is very digital
and it's quite easy to
before it got swept under the rug now we
can just you know change it around and
make it look different but the truth as
I said the truth is the truth and it's
not something that can be altered or
manipulated we all know what the truth
is and I think ultimately we all know
right from wrong and when we are
presented with that that challenge in
life we pretty much all know the right
thing to do the right thing to do now
now let's just follow through and do it
all right thank you very much no thank
you